incidente entre Estados Unidos y Rusia
en el mar Negro el mar que comparten
Ucrania y Rusia que ahora mismo es un
foco de tensión puesto que ahí es donde
el ejército ruso está condicionando con
las armas las exportaciones de grano
ucranianas la versión rusa es que ellos
no han derribado el norteamericano sino
que fue el propio aparato el que perdió
el control y después perdió altura y
acabó estrellándose contra el mar por
culpa de una maniobra brusca confirma
Moscú que sí que ellos detectaron la
aeronave sin piloto que estaba ya cerca
de las costas de crimea y que se dirigía
directo hacia la frontera Estatal de la
federación de Rusia apuntan además que
el dron iba con el traspondedor apagado
el dispositivo que se utiliza para
identificar las aeronaves
el embajador ruso en Washington ha sido
llamado a consultas del departamento de
estado y también el embajador
norteamericano aquí en Moscú ha lanzado
una dura protesta contra el Ministerio
de asuntos exteriores